okay
for people joining this live stream we
are looking at form notebooks
which are a new construct that i'm not
sure we've live streamed about before
that are coming in version 12.2
all right let's um
what is this isn't totally necessary for
today but there are some bug fixes and a
new update on on the cloud object you
don't have to do that
can i go ahead and do it sure yeah
that's fine
okay that was an error generated here
yeah shorter your cloud object isn't
permissible apparently for stephen
that's the permissions but yeah um i'll
double check it we could just move on
for now thank you
so two main things as you can see the
settings dialog and mini forms
when we looked at this last time we
wanted the spacing
to better indicate what goes under what
heading and you wanted some options of
heading styles as well
let's just take for a second let's just
look at the the bigger picture
of um uh
let's see can i go to form file new new
programmatic
um i don't think that's the right name
there
form notebook
i think we should call it form notebook
authoring i think it's too
confusing because you passed it out as
form authoring notebook
i agree i was going to suggest that
okay
that looks nice
all right so let's go let's just start
off insert
by the way does this does this correctly
magnify
no it does not magnify
noted i think it behaves the same way
that
um the function repo stuff does
i'm not 100 sure about that though do we
think this is correct
no i don't think so well it behaves way
all dark
cells behave as far as magnification
goes yeah you can change your
scaling for your desktop and that would
change how that looked like you would
magnify it but you walk for the desktop
sorry like you can change your scaling
well the screen resolution is what you
mean which i don't think steve is going
to know what happened yeah no no
exactly yeah
so i don't know what we should be doing
here i mean i don't understand
in this case i can't imagine why
changing the magnification shouldn't
change the dark cell magnification in
this case
do you understand what i'm saying for
you from a usage point of view i don't
see why you wouldn't want that
same i don't know what the argument is
but all of our doctor cells resist
magnification in the same way
even the one and the help viewer for
instance
just as palettes do right
let's ask that question i don't know the
answer it seems wrong
okay design wise there's some spacing
problems here that's too close up there
and we actually have um new designs
entirely that
that need to be decided upon that we
really like them
okay so let's say form elements
now how do i see this and it's yeah
you're seeing some buggy stuff here but
yep
that
and in the designs that we'll go over
okay it's been changed quite a bit okay
all right well so
what what should we look at these first
and then let's look at the settings
yeah if you want to look at many form
guise first
okay so this was some of ours
favorite option that's in this notebook
and then there are a lot of options down
below
well we felt that this made it clear so
that you know exactly what view you're
in
and which views you can switch to these
top two are obviously in code view if
you scroll down you can start seeing the
many forms why is it called editor
rather than edit
well aren't you editing code as well so
should it say edit code
um what's the reason code
edit scroll down it's it's the gui form
so it doesn't have to be called editor
you did not decide on that it should
have been in brackets
it's actually a form a former than a
former than a form
um
is it always the form yes
well maybe we should call it form
preview code form or is that too
unbelievably confusing
um
definitely not editable code is the
editable case
yes
is gooey too weird gui
no although gui might suggest you're
going to get the final form of the thing
you could say code text code form
our code input well i would because the
pole point is its text rather than this
raw maybe not raw well
no that's not raw but the other thing is
this one here
fields
that's not a bad idea except that
edit fields no because it's not clear
what part of speech that is um
build editor builder
oh that's nice
and honestly it's not clear what any of
these parts of speech are
builder until we find settle on the
third one
oh yeah
um
build preview no because that suggests
it's an action
is an interesting one wizard is very
1990s
actually no it isn't even that it's like
500 a.d or something whenever that was
when was merlin and those guys um
suggesting the layout but it isn't
really layout it's it's something um
this is not the final layout this is a
um
a wizard is usually a multi-step thing
builder wizard what else is in that
space
constructor
template no it's not template
that's not terrible theater it over
a template overlaps template notebook
though might get confusing
so what would what was the android site
creator
you know i actually like template
preview
code template
i don't think it's bad i think it's
clearer it's clear what the hell you're
going to get
yeah okay fine i also like template i
like template and
builder or build yeah but i think i
think build builder
you know we've got a part of speech
problem and so on and so on and so on
i mean template could be a different
part of speech as well but at least
between all of them i think we're
getting somewhere
yeah that makes sense
yeah so a couple things to decide here
then uh one are all of these options
um just taking a look at them and making
sure we want fields for all of these
which options um right below your cursor
where it expands into options required
default hint help
like the form object options that's cool
um obviously required and masked would
be
true false i didn't tell billy to do
that
meaning check boxes either check boxes
or drop downs
yeah okay so so look if we're going to
do this but
just for visual purposes group together
the the um
the ones that are check boxes or
whatever
yeah okay
um what can you put into disambiguation
is that code i don't know what that
option is i was trying to
that was a complicated thing for for
i would don't include it yeah it seems
like you can only do that in code view
um
okay i'm not sure i'd ever notice the
word options and is that the right
um you know part of interface so to
speak like part of speech
to have just an arrow like that
did you get what i'm saying i mean i'm
not sure that this is as visible
here
billy do you have any other thoughts on
there could be some sort of
visual interaction that highlights the
whole bar as you hover over it
um or we could just try different
treatments to make it stand out a little
more
i also wonder if it's like the options
thing is just
better to keep kind of small and out of
the way
if most people wouldn't be using those
options
all right okay fine all right let's
assume this is good
okay so now styling of the gui down
below
this here um yep these one two three
four five so by the way people are
asking what the point of this whole
thing is
the point of this thing this is a really
cool thing that we've wanted for a long
time
the point of this thing is to be able to
make a notebook
that you can give to people to fill out
to answer questions for example and that
then you can get the results back from
them and
that you might do that to make you know
a quiz for education you might do that
like we expect to use form notebooks all
the time for authoring our documentation
and things like this
and all of our future um you know
file new uh function repository
item um that will all be done eventually
with form notebooks
um okay this this is the authoring of a
form notebook
yeah like for example a lot of educators
right now that i've been interviewing
are using
they're like passing huge notebooks back
and forth between them and the students
and doing their own parsing of the
notebooks so this will help a lot
yes and there's a question here um
uh
um about
uh will these forms work when stored in
the cloud what is the cloud story of
these things
um well that's one of the questions for
version one is whether or not we
we surely want the end result generated
form notebook
to be usable in the cloud um and whether
or not we want
the authoring side to be in cloud for
version one is a question
i don't think we're going to make it for
version one to have the authoring on the
cloud
but but i mean if we can we should i
think it's less important i think
deployment to the cloud is very very
very important
yeah okay agreed
oops what was that um
okay all right now let's look here uh
all right
so this was okay so we're saying there's
an insert this is just to show you the
flow
once you click one of those you'll get
these options you know
the form gui and so then
down below one two three through six are
the options to choose from
you know these terms code editor gui
editor
maybe we should
nah it's too we don't want to use up
even more real estate here
you want one word yeah okay
all right let's go down here all right
so what do we have to figure out with
this
just the visual look um
this is good with that yeah i really
like number one the best but
uh you know number two it only has a
difference what's the difference
i'm gonna tell you so number two at the
top is a control drop down instead of as
its own field
you only see preview and code on the
left so whereas number one is showing
you the state you're on
number two is not
and then as you go down there are other
small changes
let's just assume it's number one yes um
i mean the only question is the selector
here is that obvious that that's a
selector
that that's means the current selection
or does it not
want to have something where
it's got an arrow from this for example
when it's selected
yeah like that kind of chevron look that
like click to copy
maybe i don't know jeremy or anybody
else want to comment on that christine
is here also
okay um
better point the right hand end of that
highlighted section on the blue
highlight
that's what you're saying i would say so
just like a
yeah and we could square off a little
bit the right hand side or the left
[Music]
right and then these ones would just be
button lock
so it wouldn't indicate that this is the
act this is what you've got here
okay all right
um no this this is not as good
this this one is best okay
okay what's next back to the settings
dialog
which is i think your tab over okay
i don't know why it's zoomed in can you
zoom out more or
i don't know yeah okay so we do have
these three options here
so the headings are all different and
then on the third one the layout on the
top is a little bit different
you would ask to try this background
color behind headings
um i think in our pre-meeting everybody
liked what's on the far right the most
and one point that jeremy wanted to make
is that um whatever we choose here
should probably be considered
you know like a standard for other
things like this in the future
i'm not a big fan of all caps stuff
um i think it's harder to read
than mixed case so what is the
difference between b and c
um other than that the uh do you see
authoring notebook style
it so the style sheet got a heading and
then this
radio button treatment which i think is
nicer than just choose style sheets oh i
agree
yeah so really in terms of layout i
think the c
wins but the heading style is what we
need input on this is a complicated page
if these pages are all this complicated
i think having more structure visually
is a good thing and so i think having
some background color or something here
or
or you know strengthening these lines is
worthwhile
like in a or differently than a
a is okay you give it a dash of color
just for liveliness
oh jeremy what do you think i worry
about the bars
i mean translating to other dialogues
that we have it's it's a bit odd
to throw that in i mean i think we could
look at color possibly i think that's
good maybe a stronger weight for sure
for b yeah i prefer
something like b but maybe maybe we
could bump up the weight a little bit
i'm not sure what weight that is
fine and and they need to go closer to
the the bars above them so
yeah and the bars could get darker yeah
all right fine and you think that that's
a
interim thing i mean we probably need to
inventory all these dialogues like this
um which is a big job yeah get them
to be consistent yeah exactly so
whatever we do here we'd want to kind of
follow into the rest of the dialogues we
have
fine but that's a big project to
inventory all that stuff
yeah um
okay so um the illuminati icon which is
not a 12.2
thing but there are more options over
there on the right if you wanted to look
at those okay
where is the illuminati going um you can
see it there under choose analytics
track personal analytics so deeper
deeper tracking of what people are doing
in the notebook
and we decided that that would show up
in the generated notebook as well and it
has this hover over
that would explain what's going on well
i think of these illuminati eyes that
one is probably the most promising
that was andre's vote
um there's also this idea of having it
like blink when you're
mouse over
um
bob is commenting that he thinks this
needs more color because education
needs to be more fun remember this is
not for the education this is for the
educators
this is the behind the scenes of
education you can make the actual form
notebook as colorful as you want
this is for the the the people who
create that
okay anything else that we need to not
in this
okay i think everybody's saying that b
and c yeah i mean i think we all agree
this one
is this one is nice it just needs you
know it needs that kind of weight
but without all caps and darker lines
right okay what's next on the agenda
these unification designs
just coming back for another round
hopefully we can make a decision this
time
okay so this is unifying toolbars
between different um
yeah all these different notebooks last
time
um you'd wanted to keep coloring for the
buttons
and to look at the trays having a
background color so that's i think oh my
god
sorry i'm just so my head is beginning
to spin with all of these
do you guys have a proposal right now
i think jeremy your favorite was column
one for sure for me
yeah just it has this nice hierarchy
coming down
with kind of you know less and less
weight as it gets down to that bottom
layer which seems right
and and some of the like three i think a
little too much color for me
i can't even get to three like
oh billy gave me an alternative link for
this if the case this happened again we
do not know why this is happening for
you
well i mean i can go to a different
browser so that can help me
i have no idea
are you serious okay
why does this happen
okay let's go to another browser
if it happens in this other browser i'm
going to be
what the heck okay
what's going on here this is not
you want to just save the image for now
i can troubleshoot with roger
well i mean what am i looking for out
here i'm looking at
i can kind of see it here so so one
versus three
first column versus third i thought the
third was just too heavy with all the
color background
go ahead the only thing i wish was part
of one was i wish there was like
that same light gray bar between the
like dark cell with the tools opener on
it
and then the actual opened content
i just think it looks weird how it just
looks like one big white oh it flows in
yeah okay here i definitely don't like
the sandwich effect
all right let's go look over here if i
can get oh my gosh
come on this is crazy you put it in a
notebook
i think that's what you did last time
yeah yes
um okay all right anyway here
so as this opens i don't really like
this white here
couldn't we have some color behind this
just to make it not look like it's
and we really want white here as opposed
to some
slight wash of color here i think we
want some kind of color here and maybe
we even want to continue this but
but a less saturated version of this
color
so i'm saying could we try just making a
light blue
underneath these things
see what i'm saying somebody try that
jeremy unless you think it's a total
failure no i i like it for the second
layer i think that'll work out fine i'm
not sure i agree the whites doesn't
quite work for data resource
but maybe the gray's fine that's an
unusual case that that
fourth level piece is unusual
which fourth level piece this that these
little stripes and
gray um yeah
this stuff here yeah that stuff doesn't
pop in that's not very common
i mean those are in all of these ex all
of these pretty much
really yeah is it in demonstrations
it will be it's not yet but okay that's
what we're working on this is the
actions after you've done things
as you this is the history of your use
of this notebook
oh that is that's all the results i
thought it was the feedback from
check we we call them result stripes
on our desktop but yeah it's the history
or feedback
same thing okay gotcha so then yeah
those are in
any other resource the definition
notebooks and they just hang around
all the time or you can access them but
they just they pop up yeah with feedback
i think that look let's try blue
going to a gray blue could somebody try
this actually right now
billy billy you're on right i assume
billy's working on this
yes yeah okay okay
okay what's that little thing there a
little piece of fluff
that's the the blob that represents the
resource
object defined by the notebook itself
remember there's this catch 22 for
data resource that that's our solution
for it's it's an elegant thing
but maybe there's a prettier icon we
could use at some point
okay yeah i wasn't a fan of the notebook
icon there
just it's confusing yeah i'd love a
different icon
but i think the the solution is nice
there we go
well what kind of icon could we use i
mean it's basically a self
you're inserting exactly yep i mean yeah
it means the the thing defined by this
notebook boy
an icon for self
i have a feeling that many icons that we
could put there are simply confusing
the only icon maybe i could imagine is
something that comes from here
that icon
even abstract it could be something like
a function repository where it's
brackets around a blob
of color right it could be a blue blob
with brackets around it maybe yeah
i know lighthouse yeah okay are you
suggesting that it's different
in different ones of these or that yeah
data would be different than
function because we're gonna we're gonna
use the same thing on service connect
so okay i suggest what it is is at the
beginning not at the end and i think it
should just be a block
a rectangular block like this that
copies the color that we got from up
here
okay and billy sent you an option an
email
okay
well it looks a lot better in my opinion
i still don't like the second and third
layers having the same
like no delineation between them but i i
thought that the
wash would be behind the first layer and
the third would be
white i don't think white is gonna work
why not just have a thin line between
the second and the third that's the
color is the top as the top dock so
the dark blue
you try that billy yeah that could work
we definitely need a separator there
so the second line underneath data
resource
for the tools and that second with all
the buttons on the right that's going to
be i don't know what what is that line
there
that indicates that tools is open
why doesn't that line just continue well
there's cases where i have multiple
tools and i forget what the other is
inside there's actually form notebook
yeah in certain tools
and you can see that over there
when they're both open there's lines
under each
and they go down to two levels they can
both drawers can be opened
could we try just having a thinner line
just continue this but with a thin line
under there
can you try that billy okay
so then the only indication that it
would be open would be the down arrow
no no no the thickening of the line here
this line is thicker than what i'm
suggesting continues
you could even thicken it even a little
bit more
i don't know i don't think we should go
to full red for demonstrations unless
we're really
forced to that is that what we're forced
to by the rest of the design
no not i don't think so what is it i
think right now is it black
let me look
i think that full red is too
it's very loud yeah i mean just
just get get us another round yeah the
or the
black like the icon i like the darker
red and two
yeah the two yes that's much better oh i
see okay
much better that's fine
okay well there was a question on a live
stream from stetson asking what
is the code font that is used
in notebooks in order to format
a in latex what is the code font
somebody here knows the code font it's
code
code source code sans source source
sounds pro i think
source code pro for for the mono yeah
source sans for the
text font so can we
how do we how do we get those would it
be current value
what is that what is it in fact current
value current value style hints
code font minus as a string so again
current value of style hints
style hints like that
as a symbol i think it might it might be
in a list
yeah style hints has a list of uh styles
it keeps so it's in a list style hints
comma or
well there you go code font source code
pro
that's the answer that's for mac it's
actually different from platform to
platform
well okay on windows it's consoleless
and on linux it's
i don't remember sorry
got an update from billy there in the
back yep
what happened to the blue here where's
the blue background
missed it in the copy hold on
okay
so the answer to stetson's question on a
live stream is that it's somewhat
complicated and depends on the platform
i wonder how latex deals with that i
have no idea
okay jesse's asking what kinds of tools
are there for programmatically creating
and manipulating form notebooks
um and i think that's what we're looking
at right now
well form notebooks have to be created
using
the like form authoring notebook
um if that makes sense
i think this looks pretty decent jeremy
i think it's a little heavy on the i
think we could lighten that for that
second layer
that i like the line i agree
two sketches lighter from the medium
yeah
these two right okay
okay so billy can try that and then we
can perhaps wrap this
okay all right anything else to look at
here
um i think just template notebook just
because it currently does not have that
branding stripe
um but if you don't see anything crazy
then
is that really the right level for those
things or should those things just go
directly to
this these kinds of items here
you see what i'm saying
i don't think this is the right level i
mean these usually we have tools and
things like that there so i think this
should go
to whatever format we're using for this
third level right the generate
stays as a second level item but all
this other stuff goes
to third level i think and generated
options might need to move over towards
generate and be like generate
right you could imagine a checking at a
play that would also be on that
first level yes well if that happens
then this has to go to insert
right but otherwise i think we could
just
treat those as third level in terms of
their appearance
and the ability to send something here
sorry i'm just um
or i mean open sample is very useful on
these things
oh wait did billy did you just send
through a lighter background case
yeah and i included the version before
it to the right of it
yeah this is this is good i think this
looks good
jeremy yeah i agree okay
okay we have a solution here
all right so let's um so let's go ahead
and apply that to all these other things
um and you just have to come up with
color values that work for all of these
various
background colors okay we've got um
uh icons for everything including
template notebook is that a new icon
billy i assume that's a new icon um
not i don't think it's new since the
last time okay
then let's just declare victory on it
okay okay
um okay are we happy with the
you know the distribution of colors here
i mean what does a
data this is kind of random if i might
say so
i mean i i'm you know right now the data
repository what is a neural net
repository the neural net repository is
green
isn't it it's green yep
okay so look we've got a lot of other
repositories coming including
what color is the is the um color
palettes repository
yeah i guess rainbow right
yeah so we need to inventory those and
make sure the colors make sense
yeah i'm not convinced that they do here
right now because i think we've got
some repositories we've got uh somebody
was asking about testing notebooks which
also need to be brought into this fold
okay wait um
okay help me out with with understanding
i mean what we've got
is some strong
uh
you know strong programmatic types of
notebooks and then we've got
things which are oh boy
[Applause]
okay we've got
these things the resource types
the yeah the definitions
what is this if it isn't an authoring
notebook why doesn't say it's an
authoring notebook it probably shouldn't
and i mean template notebook authoring
probably should also say authoring i
don't see why it shouldn't
okay i'm not sure why we need to have
the wall from demonstrations project
there
i think we should just say demonstration
should we say demonstration
because you don't have to upload the
demonstration to the demonstrations
project
true and this i mean the demonstrations
are all already in the resource system
so we're transitioning to moving that to
a definition notebook as well
okay i mean this should say
demonstration authoring
um okay color color choices here
okay i mean we could take the point of
view that all these programmatic
notebook types are have some reddish
type type
theme to them um
and you know i think the dramatic i mean
i've gotten used to the orange for the
for the um function repository and i
have no problem with it but i'm just
i mean i'm i like the color connection
to repos but kind of think there's
maybe color by class or something some
of these are different colors
just because it looks nice but could
probably
share the same color palette but so you
can't just pick new colors every time we
invent
a new notebook like this
right your point is
i think there's
yeah and kind of save our colors for
pretty special cases
what about black who gets black
black with touch of red could be common
and we need some kind of common
default it is fine
so just to understand that in terms of
the um
um you know
the menu right um
we've got a form news so let's say that
the block of things under programmatic
notebook
was whatever some one particular color
you know we've got colors here as well
i hate to say it but we've got a green
stripe there
what's that oh nothing just thinking of
course we do
and these are yet another thing which
should be unified with all of this
and it probably should say at the top um
yeah i probably should have something
about the fact that it's a script
notebook at the top
although this cell here i think works
very well
maybe this is a special case
okay the repository items so we're going
to have a lot more of these repository
items
and i don't know how we're going to keep
the colors i mean are
all uh is every repository going to get
its own color
i mean i like having that yeah
eventually they will turkey close to
each other
the icon itself right i mean great i
mean there's a website too right so
there's branding
for a whole thing the whole system
yes it's not just a notebook i think you
can imagine the notebooks keeping the
same color and
and then the the logo i don't agree i
don't agree the logo could be a
different color
that's a possibility but i don't know
why we would do that i mean given that
we're committing to a color
for the uh repo altogether why not just
have a color here
but i you know
okay let's please get an inventory okay
yes so i mean this is something maybe
bob
can get maybe um bradley is probably the
person to do this
for all the planned future repositories
okay
let's just get a list of them and let's
try and pick their colors just
as a possible you know uh possibility
for what they will be
just so we get some distribution of what
kinds of things they are
makes sense sounds fun
it does good
okay what's what's some
um saying that he was writing his
dissertation in math
and used mathematica good and um
yeah by all means get your code looking
nice for some reason people often when
they write books do not have the code
looking nice maybe we can um
does andre do you have a good kit for
people who are
including code and books we've had this
assume many times
andre tuned out
well if he comes back i know he was
having headset troubles i don't know if
i'm supposed to have troubles
um ah audio failed he said okay
well when he comes back he might give a
comment on that because i think we have
a good solution for that
okay yep i mean we at least have book
tools but i will
check up with andre
maybe you could put a link to book tools
on the livestream chat
uh yeah let me grab that for avery
brian creating notebooks solely from
code might be useful
yeah i mean i i don't know what it looks
like if you have
a you know right now we have a create
notebook function that creates from code
i i'm i suspect that it isn't as useful
as you think i i think
that um you know in the end you have to
author
the words and you really don't want to
be putting them in
character strings um
and i think in cases where you want
something to be programmatic
you can do that with a template notebook
it's a convenient way to do it
um
what i think could be nice is you know
like taking
fields from one and having a symbolic
representation like a cell object that
you can then spit into another one
right yes that would be nice right that
would be nice and i mean what
what is that you never look at never
look at the inside of the cell but just
the cell
as a almost atomic unit that you move
around
right well or alternatively something
where you just are
for example you might want some well you
could just do it as a template i mean if
you want to say
today's date or you want to
you know insert content like that
um
there's a question about polynomial ring
functions i'm sorry
utterly the wrong group of people here
the
primary decomposition ideals sorry wrong
group a
fine fine question to ask come back when
we're doing one of these about algebra
and we'll have the right people
this is not the right people um
uh okay what's next in terms of my
agenda and things that you decided for
12.2 that
is it um we have to make a decision on
whether or not this is included in
wolfram alpha notebook edition we're
meeting with that team on wednesday
to talk about more but especially with
these many forms it seems like
um you can author these without coding
and so it may be a really good candidate
i think i think we do want it there i
think that the educators who use wolf
enough for notebook addition this is
highly relevant to them yep
okay and i i mean my only question is in
an authored form notebook
can you have inputs which go through off
now for notebook edition
do you understand what i'm saying in
other words you say to some student you
know enter the result for this thing
can they be typing it into a free form
cell in the
built form notebook from
from the form notebook authoring system
i mean using the like our style sheet so
yes i
i mean if we wanted to lock that down i
think we also could
no but is that naturally going to just
work
uh lou is there a reason why it wouldn't
well all these things go through forms
right so forms have interpreters that
hit alpha i don't know if there's a
generic
is there a generic wolfram language
interpreter built in that's accessible
via forms
i don't know well
no i'm confused too because in why have
i got two notebook edition icons i don't
even
know but i'll try this one but if i look
at notebook edition
right
um
when it starts up my question is
okay i'm authoring one of these things
but then i want people to enter where is
it
okay it's kind of stripe city when
you've got um
all of these different things here okay
all right so i've got one of these
things
right can i author a form notebook to
say
put in other words is one of the types
of
uh wherever it is in a form notebook
right says one of the
yes does it have one of these in it
no oh i think the only thing you can
insert are
form form things or you free form
area in the notebook it's form object
stuff or you don't have a
control equals interpreter type i mean
could you
you could use that with the editable
notebook area perhaps
how would you even get one of these how
do you even get one of these boxes
um i think in a typical notebook it's
shift control
nine really
maybe a shift command nine
you're saying that's correct i had no
idea
and it's no that should be advertised in
the menu as well in the style
listing in the format menu
yes shift command 9.
fancy that i had no idea
why is code text at that position there
does it have to be
why isn't code text up higher up
there under text code text
um okay what's this
cloud support uh you you answered that
already
um so we don't need to okay
all right what's happening with this um
what's this oh course for repository
um sylvia was assigned to that so we
agreed with you to
um put that behind the form notebook and
language level stuff because
all of that is kind of a precursor to
the repository anyway
okay okay all right
um okay so then the next iteration of
this these design changes can go in
and we should be pretty much ready good
to go and ready for the freeze right
yep need to implement and then after the
freeze we come back about q
a authoring notebooks
mean the question yeah okay which
requires the question object
stuff and so on yep okay good and it
seems like the assessment function stuff
finally as of this morning is pretty
much in good shape
right bob yeah yep
okay okay good stuff all right
anything else nope okay thanks a lot
everybody here and thanks to folks on
the live stream
and